[La musique]
[Applaudissements]
au
[La musique]
caporal
pnl non pas pitié maintenant ça frappe
cette raison
j'espère, laisse-moi
paris ce gamin je vois ça par courtoisie
oh hey 4 kill et atk
vraiment là en java la radio rouge
maintenant aux voisins oh [ __ ] d'aller et jamais le
mignonne
c'est alors
détail animaux cela tombe il est en activité
ça quand ça peut le faire
rabo cola
plutôt arie punto à partir de quelques euros jamais ça
est le maintenant ce que punto
comment ne peuvent-ils pas tuer ici
objectif unique 2009 tous d'accord pas
bref je ne viens pas de loin et le fun ou tout
à et patrice
peux-tu ce que tu veux pour t'y emmener
pourtant la cérémonie du fil est terminée sun die
aboutaleb jt peut être un déchet plus rouge dans
c'est encore
la chatte a passé un bon moment
je choisis ce mec
ok je suis là avec
[Applaudissements]
[La musique]